my dad had various nicknames for me he'd
call me Fireball sometimes because I'd
start little businesses he didn't care
about money at all he believed very much
in having an inner scorecard and I never
worry about what other people are
thinking about you you know just just uh
if you know why you're doing what you're
doing that's good enough
well I want to do something I always
want to do it big I've said many times
that that 65 or 70 and the people that
you want to have love you actually do
love you
you're a success some people should not
own socks at all because they just get
too upset with price fluctuations if
you're going to do dumb things because
your stock a stock goes down you
shouldn't own a stock at all the first
books I read on investment were actually
in my dad's office I just read and read
and read I probably read five to six
hours a day I mean I figured out very
early you don't have to be that smart of
this business which is fortunate but you
do have to have the right temperament
the best gift I was ever given was to
have a father that I had when I was born